people are living decades longer we all
like this story than ever than they ever
have before thanks to advances in
medicine and public health so we asked
some Californians to explain what ou
means to them the body is not quite as
flexible few more wrinkles the first 30
words that come to mind when I hear the
word old our retirement menopause and
Beach I would say feeling old is
probably when you turn 70 because the
number is a scary number
usually the lack of mobility just kind
of sit around and don't do much there is
an upside to aging I would say the
knowledge you gain through your life you
start kind of appreciating family and
community a little bit more I am not
confined by limitations that society
might have put on me
when I was young you just keep growing
and changing and you become more wise
and I think that the most beautiful
thing about aging retirement
[Music]
dr. Louise Aronson wrote the new book
elder hood redefining aging transforming
medicine reimagining life in it she says
we should look at the final third of
life with the same concern curiosity
creativity and rigorous review the first
two thirds dr. Aronson is an expert on
aging and a professor of medicine she
joins us first on CTM to talk about her
book and we were we were all looking
forward to this conversation earlier in
the in the broadcast there was an
interview with a woman on the street who
said about Joe Biden you know I don't
know if I want an old guy over the age
of 60 to run for president and Anthony
and I both sort of flinched I found your
book to be encouraging and discouraging
at the same time I also think that the
definition of Aging seems to change for
everybody it does in surveys the older a
person is the more likely they are to
define age as older right so we we all
basically define it in ways that enable
our current self so younger people think
youth last longer and old age starts
sooner and old people the other way and
what's the reality in terms of what
lasts longer the reality is across all
cultures and for millennia
everybody has defined old ages beginning
between the ages of seven sixty and
seventy that will surprise many people
especially people who are in their 60s
yeah but you call this a transformative
period it's absolutely it's a watershed
moment in human history so throughout
all of human history previously we've
had lots of children and a fair number
of adults and very few older people and
now the entire population is changing so
that we're going to have about the same
numbers of people in all categories and
more and more older people so we need to
change our policies and choices our
worlds our restaurants our
transportation or healthcare bathrooms
what myths do you want to be bunk about
aging well in the first place the
biggest myth is that it's horrible and
it isn't so in studies they find
consistently
that older people are happier than
adults why what over the age of you
begin to get happier in your late 50s
and then you become happy or still in
the happiest times of life or in the 60s
70s and
early 80s why is that why is that so
there are a bunch of reasons I think
part of it is that people are
comfortable with who they are they're
very clear on their priorities they have
moved through the stress of the most
ambitious sort of Sandwich Generation
years of adulthood and they're just
happier being who they are and making
good choices you called the Sandwich
Generation because you're making school
lunches every day yes that's part of it
there is a u-bend and I think it's very
early because of career ambitions and
stress at work but also because you're
in the thick of it with small children
you're making a marriage work off and
what does medicine need to do how does
it need to change in order to deal with
the fact that so many more people are 70
and above now right so medicine like all
other aspects of society was basically
built at a time where we had lots of
kids and a fair number of adults so
let's take medical school for example
it's four years long would you get a few
months training about kids and most of
the rest of the four years is about
adults a few hours training about worse
about older people and in hospitals
about 40% of patients are older people
and yet most doctors have hours of
training in their care so if you go to
the doctor and you say my left knee
hurts and you're an older American and
and the doctor was like yeah it's just
age what do you say how do you push back
against that well there was actually a
real man that Luisi I hate that but it
was a real patient here in New York who
had that experience of what he said to
the doctor was 97 year old man right 97
year old man my other knee is also 97
[Laughter]
not doing her dad if we're lucky we get
a third act and we really should embrace
that yes well it's one of the happiest
times of life it lasts for decades
I mean think of all the terms we have
for childhood infant toddler tween teen
and we act as if old age is a singular
state when in fact from your 60s to your
hundreds you change that's generations
of yes it's not it's not a tony
categorize the new it created a new
category super old there are super Agers
we'll say 60s a new forty 70s a new 50
is that okay I actually think that's
completely Aegeus because what you
suggest is that it's never good
6060 is only good if you're actually
acting like and looking like you're 40
whereas in fact people at age 60 are
much happier than people at age 40 so
let's own that you know it's super old
now seems super fun to me I'm looking
for thank you very much for being here
elder hood is on sale today